hey everyone welcome to another episode
of unlocking lily so I believe that
every single human being is capable of
extraordinary things when they embrace
who they truly are evan is currently an
investor in my business and he's helping
me grow my coaching and speaking
practice and it's absolute honor to have
you guys join me on my startup journey
so guys I have been incredibly stressed
out over the last couple of weeks in
planning my trip to Thailand I'm going
to be going there for at least two
months and the thought of it is just
making me sick I'm trying to plan out
the schedule I'm trying to figure out
the time zones I'm trying to figure out
where I'm gonna be living and all of
this has got me really stressed and to
top it all off I had to deal with a lot
of personal - I just recently lost my
passport actually that's the morning
I've been running around trying to
figure out my password situation so my
stress has been at the all-time high and
that's not a good way to live at all
because it was physically making me sick
so you guys might be experiencing
similar things in your life right now
whether if it's you moving to a
different country or you are graduating
from school or you're changing careers
or you're going through a huge life
experience right now stress is
inevitable and it happens in our lives
whether you like it or not and the
reality is it's not the fact that it's
gonna happen to you and Dawn is the
weight we deal with it so I really
needed to like open up my toolbox and
try to figure out ways to cope with this
massive stress and panic attack
been having over the past couple of
weeks I use two different mindfulness
technique and one incredible mindset
technique that helped me get through the
past couple of weeks so the first one
that I use is called stop is a
mindfulness practice I have been using
for years now I used to have severe
panic attacks and anxiety when I worked
in the corporate world because I would
constantly stress about the past and how
I used to regret certain actions that I
did and also I would have massive
anxiety around the unknown around the
future to the point that would just make
myself sick so stop is an actual acronym
so the first thing is the s and the stop
so s stands for stop so when you feeling
panic attack coming around you feel like
everything is spiraling out of control
you feel complete chaos and can't ground
yourself the first thing you want to do
is to stop what you're doing and take a
moment that's it just stop everything
you do it and now the T and the stop is
to take a few breaths it's amazing how
much deep breathing could really help us
cope with our anxiety and stress so you
deal with me right now just take - two
or three breaths right here so you're
gonna take a deep breath in and exhale
take a deep breath in again exhale
see you probably already feel better
taking a few breaths makes a massive
difference now the O and the stop is to
observe your thoughts and emotions a lot
of the times we have these crazy
thoughts of doomsday for example for me
and like I'm gonna get lost what if I
can't figure out the time zones I'm
gonna lose all my clients my clients are
gonna think that I'm the worst coach in
the world what if I can't do this and
what if I get what if I lose my money
what if I get attacked on the street
like all of these crazy thoughts why
because I was feeling so much anxiety
around the unknown so I just allow those
thoughts to just go behind as clouds I'm
like okay that's fine these are the
thoughts I'm having I'm not gonna judge
it I'm gonna acknowledge it's there and
I'm gonna try not to run with it
you're just allowed to go by observe the
thoughts allowed to go by maybe have
some thoughts right now that you're
thinking about just don't judge it don't
even judge yourself for having those
thoughts because sometimes we have lazy
thoughts and sometimes we have a
tendency of judging ourselves we're like
don't don't have an argument with
yourself okay just allowed to go and now
the pea and the stock is to proceed with
your day and when you do proceed with
your day you want to do something that
is very supportive of you what are the
things that bring you joy makes you feel
calm and grounded so for example for me
immediately when I go outside and I feel
fresh air on my face and a little Sun on
my face
Oh immediately I calm right
so what is it for you is it to take a
nature walk like what I do do you need
to go pet your puppy do you need to
drink a cup of tea do you need to go
call a friend do you need to just take a
nap do you need to meditate whatever
that looks like after you do the sto
with a P just perceiver whatever it is
the most important for you and again
there's no judgement rather it could be
anything maybe you want to dance dance
like a crazy person that's fine too
so to recap it quickly stop stands for
stop S stands for stop T stands for take
a few breaths
o stands for observe your thoughts and P
proceed with your day so now that's why
mindfulness technique that I have used
for years and has been tried and true
and it works like a charm every single
time for me now the second one is very
new
I've only been researching in about a
week and it's pretty amazing and I'm
plan on doing a little bit more research
around it so it's quite new but I still
I'm excited to share with you guys so
I'm going to do it right now so it's
called creating a future from the
unknown so then our bodies starts to
panic when we feel like we don't know
what's going on our mind starts to
wander because I've never been to
Thailand before my entire life I've
never been away from Canada for two
months or longer
like I'm panicking because I don't know
and immediately I have all these
doomsday type fonts coming through and
it's make
he's sick now if I could make myself
sick physically and have a panic attack
with my thoughts I probably could make
myself feel amazing with my thoughts
because our brain doesn't know any
different if we're truly present it
actually thinks it's true one of the
things that I have researched is from
dr. Dispenza and he talks about just
closing your eyes and you wanted to
think about what are the intentions and
the feelings and the behavior that you
want in your future because the reality
is you cannot predict the future you
cannot predict where exactly you're
going to be and what's about to happen
and who you're going to be around but
what you can do is you set the
intentions and the behaviors and the
feelings that you want so that way your
brain tells your body that it's okay
everything is just gonna be fine so
that's what I did i sat for 30 minutes
and I just felt what I wanted to feel I
want to feel gratitude I want to feel
contentment I want to feel calmness I
want to feel curiosity I want to feel
loved I want to feel just complete over
having took this because I've been so
all over the place and I just sat there
for 30 minutes I know in the beginning
was really hard
again I started judging myself for it
and doing all of those crazy things as I
always do and I just sat and just really
felt the feelings and you could do it
too maybe right now if you're sitting or
you're standing wherever just close your
eyes and just feel the feelings you want
to feel whether if that's calmness
groundedness
curiosity excitement joyfulness whatever
it is just really feel it and when
you're really present in the moment your
brain actually thinks that particular
thing is true because how many times
have you been in a situation that we
think these negative thoughts and we
make ourselves sick even though none of
that is even true so we could actually
do the reverse now again this is
something that's very new for me that
I'm still doing a lot of research around
and I'm very curious about it so if you
guys know anything additional
information about this please write in
the comments I would love to do more
research around it one person I'm
researching right now is dr. Dispenza so
if you guys have more information just
let me know and the last one is probably
the most important one of them all is
not a mindfulness practice not a
meditation it's a general mindset to
have is to trust in yourself because
you're amazing
I'm amazing we're all amazing and we
have gone through way worse in our lives
than what you're experiencing right now
and you're probably gonna experience
harder things to come but you need to
trust you something you are going to
find all the answers and the solutions
that you're required to get through this
moment because you're much bigger than
this moment and having that mindset
constantly is going to help you get
through any bad day or about here or a
bad month and that's what has helped me
significant
I realized that the reason why I was so
distressed is because I was putting all
of my trust and other things I was
trusting the internet more than I was
trusting myself I was trusting people
more than I was trusting myself even
though they're amazing human beings and
they're all helping me out but I was
depending on other people I was relying
on all of these different different
conditions that have nothing to do with
me and I was so chaotic everything
around me was just spinning around me
and the only thing that could have
grounded me was myself I am always a
sinner and so are you you are always the
center of your universe you are always
there and the only person that you have
to be concerned about is yourself
and having that unshakable trust in
yourself is what's gonna help you get
through the worst of days so guys I
really wanted to share those three
things with you because it has helped me
significantly and I know a lot of you
write in to me telling me that you're
going to put a lot of stress anxiety and
depression and all sorts of negative
emotions and I really want to share what
I do to help myself to help you as well
and have a special shout out for like
for Julia Julia thank you so much for
writing that beautiful comment in my
last episode you support means a lot to
me and finally the question the day is
what is that one thing you're really
stressing about right now write in the
comments below and I'll join and call
the discussion thank you guys so much
for watching this is my last episode I'm
filming here in Toronto the next episode
I am going to be in Thailand so thank
you so much guys I feel like this has
been quite the journey and it's about to
get way crazier in way wilder and I
cannot wait to have you guys and join me
over there thank you guys so much again
and I'll see you guys very very soon
life terrific
world domination honey Empire right I'm
grateful I understand why I'm here I
think because I am so open I wanted to
think and see it's a bloody brief life
all of you have the potential for
enormous success if you want to know
what garyvee DJ khalid oprah and others
know about empire building that most
people miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video